i think we have travis uh here with us
now travis what's going on man
how are we doing sir uh you know just
pretty chill day here watching bitcoin
seem to fall out of the sky as people
freak out a little low-key monday here i
mean great timing for you and i to go
ahead and decide that we were gonna do
this uh let's start maybe with uh like a
little bit of just market structure in
general the last two years has been
pretty incredible for bitcoin obviously
you know start of 2020 was kind of
around eight ten thousand dollars ran
all the way up to 69 000 back in
november
what's your general read on like maybe
why some of that occurred and how much
of it is like bitcoin or crypto market
stuff versus just you know the fed
stepped in it was going to pump asset
prices and bitcoins volatile so it went
up
yeah if i was going to boil it down to
one thing well i guess it would be like
two sort of market adages one is don't
fight the fed
and the other one is it's all one trade
okay and don't don't fight the feds been
around for
at least a decade
and
uh it's all one trade it's been around
for the last two years
and and basically what both of those
kind of speak to is the same backdrop
which is
central bank actions
in the current monetary regime have such
an overwhelming
overwhelmingly powerful impact on all
asset prices
that basically everything else is is
almost just an afterthought and that was
the backdrop for
the run up after the covet crash
and that's now you know the backdrop
heading the other direction as the fed
is uh is trying to tighten monetary
policy yeah i tend to agree that that is
a uh uh a huge driver if not the the
only thing really to pay attention to
right here uh what i want to do today is
talk about bitcoin but i want to use it
as kind of a discussion point for more
of like the macro environment and a lot
of the stuff that's going on there uh if
you subscribe to this idea of it is all
one trade bitcoin to me seems like it's
the most pure macro asset maybe but it's
still part of this kind of larger legacy
financial market and so you sent out a
recent update we've pulled a couple of
the
charts out of there that i thought just
were home runs frankly and the first one
and i thought it was very telling this
was like the first thing that you led
with was the price of bitcoin and you
overlaid a tweet uh on top of it and the
tweet uh says the former new york fed
governor dudley if stocks don't fall the
fed needs to force them and it was
citing a cnbc uh interview and that was
back in kind of early april which
obviously was part of this like price
relief rally after bitcoin had dropped
50
and so talk to me a little bit about
this like mentality coming from the fed
whether active officials or former
officials of like they seem to think
that they are in control and they know
exactly what they're doing
yes
i think there's there's two things i
speak to about that chart the first one
is just how tightly
nasdaq and bitcoin are trading with each
other and you can just see that they're
overlaid uh on top of one another and
they look like exactly the same
and then the second thing that i added
was was that tweet
uh
which was was basically a former fed
governor writing a bloomberg
op-ed article that was entitled like the
like what it says in that tweet if if
stocks don't fall the fed should force
them to fall
which is
uh you know a pretty crazy thing for
these boomers to be running around
saying
but they are
dead set on fighting inflation they're
terrified of inflation inflation is um
you know the hot button political item
uh the fed has become deeply politicized
the the the notion of an independent
uh federal reserve i think is is a joke
at this point
and
uh
and and and so
the the the fed has a few different
mechanisms that they think through
uh trying to
sort of tame inflation with but but one
of them is through this mechanism called
financial conditions and there's there's
an index you can type into trading view
or bloomberg the financial conditions
index which is a combination of a few
different things but two of the inputs
in into
financial conditions are uh equity
prices and uh debt prices fixed income
prices
and and so one way to tighten financial
conditions
is to
make
stocks this price of stocks fall
make the price of bonds fall
and by doing so
the fed has this view that
through sort of wealth effect
people's net worth is going down because
they're long stocks they're long bonds
the prices of those are going down their
net worth is going down as their net
worth is going down it makes them
uh buy less things uh spend less money
and then that has a you know uh an
effect of obtaining inflation over time
and so that that was that was really
what what dudley was speaking to
and and other other fed officials as
well too and and and so it's in the it
gets you into this pretty
you know kind of creepy
spot of
um
you know the fed feeling like the best
way for them to try and get inflation
under control is to just hit everybody's
net worth and they can do that with
uh you know maximum jawboning
uh and then how much of that jawbone you
know so job owning is just this term of
like you know talking
a big game about something and then how
much of that talk actually translates
into
action then sort of remains to be seen
and is what's going to be
front and center over the coming months
so we've got a chart um that you put in
the update which also has kind of the
pricing of um interest rates and the
expect expectation it's kind of this
nice little curve uh that the market is
pricing in up to 10 interest rate hikes
uh and ultimately getting to three
percent uh we currently sit at 0.75
and given how big the sell-off is uh i
guess one just like how much weight do
you actually put into uh kind of ten or
so interest rate hikes and getting to a
three percent uh interest rate versus
there's no way they get there and the
fed will have to capitulate on this plan
you know well in advance
yes so it would be my pretty high
conviction based case that they are not
going to get to 10 total rate hike hikes
in 2022 and that the market
is going to
force them to slow down
before they get there
and
you know part of the reason why
i'm you know i would say
bullish
uh how would i frame this
uh
bullish from here
through the rest of the year
you know over a sort of you know seven
month time frame
is that
when the market realizes
that the fed
is not going to hike that many times
then the
expectation of tightening will be
greater than the amount of tightening
that actually comes to fruition
and that that will provide a backdrop
for
asset prices to have a relief rally as
less tightening
than jawboned
comes to fruition if that makes sense it
makes complete sense and uh i'm of the
same belief i may take it one step
further uh i can't remember if i said it
was like a 70 confidence level that i
actually think the fed may have to cut
interest rates at least one time this
year so the thought process would be as
they continue to hike interest rates
they enter that environment that you
just described where uh they got to slow
down or they they skip over a couple of
times where they thought they were gonna
hike
i even think they may go further where
given that midterm elections are coming
if they hike interest rates enough they
push us into a recession all of a sudden
you know the only thing worse than high
inflation going into uh an election is
an actual recession and so do they give
us kind of like a gut check do they say
hey you know what actually let's cut one
time uh to kind of give some confidence
back to the market to try to equalize uh
where we're at what's the level of maybe
confidence or thought process that that
could occur
yeah so it would not be my base case
that they would cut this year certainly
not out of the realm of possibility i
mean you can just see it in
just in prices today and over it's worth
mentioning that this monthly went out
uh
may 1st so this is kind of nine days old
and everything's gotten much worse in
the last nine days so like every single
one of these charts like looks
meaningfully more pukey
right this second than it did nine days
ago when this monthly came out
and i think that
looking
at how much the market is forcing the
fed's hand right now
i think that they
want to hurry up and get back to
a quote unquote neutral rate to get back
to two percent but they just hiked 50
bips i think it's highly likely that
they hike another 50 bips in june
and then another 50 bips in what
probably another 50 bits in july and
that'll get us to nearly
two percent interest rates right around
two percent
and then there's no meeting in august
but there's the jackson hole you know
very large kind of
meeting of the mines every year jackson
hole with the fed that's at the end of
august
and then
you have
a fed meeting in the middle of september
and i think by the time you get to
jackson hole
or that fed meeting in september
you could have a set up where
asset prices have you know continued to
fall a lot
and then i think this is going to be all
eyes on leading
inflation and economic growth indicators
and it's my
you know i would say medium conviction
base case that all of those are going to
show month over month declines you know
basically starting last month and then
we've had peak inflation
and you're going to see those
uh
those leading indicators you know
continue to roll over over the coming
months and that's going to give the
cover
that the fed needs under their uh
um
mantra of being data dependent and so uh
by being dependent they'll be able to
uh slow slow tightening
and uh and then probably pause
tightening you know maybe they go
25 bits
in
july or in september instead of 50 bips
and then
the market will be watching all of that
and be
sort of centering around uh
this slowdown
and like i said it's all one trade and
don't fight the fed and so a slowdown in
tightening
relative to expectations these 10 rate
hikes i think provide the backdrop for
relief for ali later on this year yeah
it makes complete sense um one of the
things that i keep going back to is this
idea of uh if it is all one trade how
much pain will they allow for the
average person to suffer uh and so
recession i think most people are like
oh that sounds bad uh but obviously when
things get overheated people make really
stupid financial decisions uh and we've
got a chart here that you included in
the update uh that bloomberg had where
they had a model 6040 portfolio and
they're showing that
it is having its worst year since 2008
and so if already in 2022 the 60 40
portfolio which is kind of the standard
in you know kind of the retail asset
management game if that's having its
worst year and they continue to hike
it seems like this could get really
nasty
uh in that 60 40 portfolio
is there any framework or thought
process that you use to kind of say like
here's the max pain that is allowed or
is it literally there is no kind of
lower bound and hey they're going to
keep hiking the interest rates so they
get inflation and if you're the sucker
taking the taking it on the chin then
you know you're the sucker
yeah so so a couple things i'll say on
that
you know one that chart you just showed
looks way worse nine days later so i'd
say that's you know that's the first
thing i would say
um on on a recession
i think it remains to be seen whether or
not the fed can engineer
like a
kiss
to zero gdp growth and then kind of back
higher a quote-unquote soft landing or
whether or not they're just going to
hammer this thing straight into a
recession i i think when you look at the
totality
of the way the fed has acted
uh over the last couple decades
it is not my base case
that they would
when you look at like what they have
done
what they can do
and what they're incentivized to do
hammering this thing straight into a
recession does not make a ton of sense
to me
it makes more sense to me
that they would try and
maximum jawbone right now which which
they're doing you know you got these got
dudley writing an op-ed saying we gotta
crash stocks a lot of these other
fed officials are when they talk you
know a lot a lot of real hawkish
jawboning and that they're they're
really trying to jawbone inflation
down over the coming months and economic
growth is going to go with it
and if they can get that into an okay
spot
then they can just kind of back off and
maybe you can kind of get this like kiss
of a zero gdp growth and then back up
and then resuming
you know
so you know so like prior to covid we
were in the longest
slowest
economic expansion in u.s history
with
uh pretty low unemployment
and very low inflation
uh
the the the fed was barely able to kind
of keep
its two percent inflation target
but that was a tremendous time to own
any kind of assets if you owned any sort
of assets over that period of time you
did really well
and the fed's constituents are boomers
and boomers own all the assets there's a
very good time to be a boomer and i
think they want to i don't see any
reason why they wouldn't want to
recreate that
now which is why which is part of the
reason why i think it's my it's my base
case that they would just try and manage
through this sort of soft landing and
then you go on pause
with the fed funds at you know somewhere
around two percent
and you get inflation back down to
you know two two and a half maybe three
percent
and that that's a fine outcome
and and you know in terms of things that
i i would be watching
that the fed might be watching i know
they're paying a lot of attention to
financial conditions
which like i said can tighten through
the decline of of stock and bond prices
the the fed gets very nervous
with uh short-term funding markets
um
financial markets globally uh this is a
debt based uh uh financial system
globally a ton of debt uh it all runs by
borrowing lots of money and there's the
short-term funding market where
you know
many many many billions of dollars are
borrowed uh overnight in between banks
and financial institutions and from the
fed and to the fed and back and forth
all of that plumbing has to work
seamlessly all of the time and when
there's even a small hiccup in that
short-term funding market
those
hiccups
metastasize into everything else very
quickly the fed is terrified of that and
they that is the sort of thing that they
will not let get out of hand
for long at all before they step in
because this whole thing's a big rickety
piece of [ __ ] and uh when the short-term
funding markets start to
uh show stress that is a sign that the
jenga tower is looking quite wobbly and
and so that would be something to pay
attention to
um
and then i think i just i just look at
uh the move index
which is the um
the move index is like the vix for bonds
it's like the volatility of of yields
basically and the move index is in a
tough spot right now it is very elevated
um and if that were to see a spike
that's the type of thing
that uh sort of
uh precedes the type of hiccup in
short-term funding markets so
those are the sorts of things that are
sort of the
flashing
red
alarm bell going off type of stuff um
and they are looking on the verge of
having problems right now and like look
you may fast forward a couple weeks and
all that looks way way worse and you
know we may be done way sooner that you
know that than i i would think but it's
just it's the kind of thing worth paying
attention to every day
so let's take your base case of kind of
we end up somewhere around two percent
uh and then they kind of chill out a
little bit uh bitcoin today is trading
somewhere around thirty two thousand
five hundred dollars thirty three
thousand dollars and i use bitcoin as a
proxy for uh the crypto market overall
um when you think about that base case
how do you balance in your head uh macro
impact on crypto prices with what i'll
call more of the like micro market
structure of crypto and so using bitcoin
as the example we know realized price is
somewhere 24 25 000 we know that you
know 60 65 of bitcoin hasn't moved in a
year but we also know that the fed is
you know basically trying to nuke uh
asset prices and so like when you're
evaluating what could happen and it's
all probabilistic but like how much
emphasis do you put on macro and fed
activity versus you know bitcoin or
crypto people are crazy they're holding
these assets there is no price at which
they'll sell and like there's some
safety there like how do you balance
those
yeah um
we definitely look at both in our
investment process
and we look at the i say the
crypto micro market structure from a
pretty quantitative perspective
and then we have a more kind of
qualitative
overlay that incorporates both kind of
crypto qualitative
fundamental
you know news flow type of stuff and
also macro
and
macro is
major league in the driver's seat right
now you know i think the first chart you
put up about the you know how tightly
bitcoin's correlated to the nasdaq
proves that point
i don't see a reason why
over
the immediate term
that bitcoin would or crypto broadly
would be able to
decouple from macro um
you know it's all one trade is it that's
as locked in now as it ever has been
um i do think that when bitcoins 50 off
of its recent high like it is right now
i do think you get into a situation
where
you know
the supply demand imbalance in terms of
the people the market participants that
are willing to sell bitcoin
more than 50 off of the top
relative to the market participants that
are willing to
dollar cost average
buying bitcoin
50 plus percent off of the top
that that imbalance does start to swing
you know much more heavily in favor of
the buyers and we're we're very clearly
in that zone right now
um
we're coming up on
a spot
that's pretty important where we're a
couple thousand dollars below current
price is the uh late july 2021 lows
uh the bitcoin held if if we were to
lose that level
which would happen with a backdrop of uh
you know even more stress in traditional
markets than we're seeing right now some
of those stress points that i was just
talking about a second ago
you know i think it could get pretty
gappy to the downside if we lose that
that 2930k level and you could see a lot
of bitcoin spot bitcoin change hands
down there in the kind of kind of
mid-20s range for bitcoin and and that's
usually the type of capitulatory price
action that marks cyclical bottoms
and
you know i think there's there's a
decent chance we could see that that in
you know coming up uh but those would be
you know generational buying
opportunities that's like you know
you're buying for your kids kids at 24
000 bitcoin and and and so
one of the things that makes this setup
different than prior setups
is that the cat is out of the bag in
terms of
what asset
asset class you want to own
when the fed eventually
slows down on tightening or goes on
pause
you know and then eventually sort of
goes back to a looser monetary policy
that's very different than the like 1819
bear market
when
the vast majority of of institutional
capital wasn't involved in this at all
and didn't have any idea how to think
about this asset class i i think that
makes for for just a very different
backdrop just
the cat's out of the bag like when the
fed goes on pause there's nothing on
planet earth that's going to move faster
off of the bottom than crypto i'm highly
convicted of that i think a lot of smart
money is highly convicted of that and
and
this this tightening phase that the fed
is in
everybody knows that this is a pit stop
until you go on pause and then
eventually cut rates again and so all of
that combines into like a pretty
interesting situation where
yeah you know it's it's you know stocks
are nuking right now traditional's
nuking right now uh crypto's nuking
right now but if you're not a forced
seller uh
this is a terrible time to be selling
crypto to be selling bitcoin and if you
got cash on the sidelines you know
you're setting up for like a an
incredible buying opportunity so it's
fascinating to kind of hear you talk
through this not not not financial
advice of course not financial advice
nothing on this show's financial advice
entertainment purposes only uh one of
the things that ends up being uh really
interesting is if we go back to 2018 uh
and we look bitcoin had peaked in 2017
at 20 000 it had drawn down and it was
sitting somewhere around six thousand
dollars or so five thousand dollars so
it drawn down like 75 percent and i
think a lot of people were like oh
it's down 75 percent like this is the
bottom quote-unquote and they're getting
very excited
obviously it puked all the way down and
eventually hit i think it was like 3200
give or take uh and it was uh very much
a puke right there was kind of this
grind down to 75 percent drawdown and
then and you hit that 3200 uh and then
pretty much from there once you hit the
bottom grind it up and and everyone
knows kind of what happened from there
is your expectation from a market
standpoint that uh these types of
markets will just grind down eventually
hit some bottom and then recover or do
you think that there is kind of that
puking or that final capitulation that
occurs uh that could uh send prices down
you know i don't know maybe a couple
thousand dollars in one kind of rabid
move or like how do you think about just
the the expectation you would have for
uh what will eventually be the bottom
whether it's now or you know some lower
price
yeah
but
for a bunch of different reasons the
setup here is not comparable to november
2018 it's just it's just not the same
for a bunch of different reasons
it's a much bigger asset class
it's a much more institutionalized asset
class that was a almost entirely retail
driven market
and
you had this hangover
from 2017
that was
much more
excessive than the price action that we
had in in 2021 in 2020 and 2021 um
especially in bitcoin i would say
and so
i i i struggled to compare the two
i struggled to compare
the 6k level that we bounced off of in
2018 a bunch of times before we broke in
november and got cut in half i i don't
think that's comparable to like say this
29k level
from july 2021 that's not to say that i
don't think we can lose 29k this time
around
because if the stress gets bad enough in
traditional which there's quite a decent
chance that it could we could lose that
29k level um
but
the
and it could like i said it could get
pretty pukey um
but the
i think the ability and the willingness
for the market
to look through
uh
the short-term volatility and that
short-term pukiness
to to look at this asset class broadly
in bitcoin specifically and say this
stuff is all much higher a few years
from now
just makes now incomparable to
uh
to like that 2018 time frame when like
you know people just thought all this
stuff could go away after that after
that uh november 2018 price crash and
one of the things that i i remind people
of a lot because in this monthly market
update that we've been looking at charts
in
i i have these monthly highlights like a
bullet point of like
my subjective view on
the most impactful
sort of news announcements over the
course of of the month
and one of the things that i track
pretty closely that's just been
astonishing is the amount of venture
capital coming into this space
and the magnitude the breadth and depth
of the capital raises for projects
and then
the amount of of vc fund fundraisers so
like the funds themselves and then
the projects that they've been funding
and you put that together and just like
the aggregate amount of capital
permanent capital that's permanent
capital that's coming into this space
is stunning and completely different and
you're talking about hundreds of
projects that have that already have
years of runway today
and then vcs with billions and billions
of dry powder that they're sitting on
today if not another dollar is raised
into crypto vc
and all of that is going to be
deployed over the course of this year
and next year and the year after that if
not another dollar of permanent capital
comes into this space and it is that
capital that will
fund the
projects and the innovation that will
drive
additional adoption
that will you know put a bottom in for
this market and cause all of this to
head higher than it ever has been before
and like i'm about as highly convicted
on that as i can be on anything yeah i
tend to think that uh everything
involved with the fear of the market is
very very short-term uh we could be
talking weeks right i don't think that
uh this continues for six months and
then we get a bottom or anything like
that like it feels uh maybe we're not
quite there yet but definitely there's
way more fear than uh uh than usual and
and so that usually tends to be a pretty
good uh indicator talk to me about uh
there's two different
elements of the market i see people
talking about uh on the internet a lot
uh i don't know if you necessarily have
unique thoughts here but but just i
think people hearing kind of how you
view them given uh the investment
strategy that you all have at ikea guy
the first is michael saylor he's
accumulated a ton of bitcoin uh he
recently put uh what i would consider a
pretty small position it seems like
where he borrowed against some bitcoin
and bought extra uh
do you worry at all that there's like a
price where bitcoin could get so low
that uh he would become a for seller
accelerate downward price pressure or
like like what's kind of the the risk
maybe of somebody like a michael sailor
and micro strategy to a market from if
you're just looking at price right
obviously there's a ton of benefit like
how do you just
evaluate what that uh impact would be on
the market or what you're paying
attention to there
yeah
so a couple things i'll say on sailor
one
after their latest earnings called it
was like widely
misquoted
or taken out of context
of what
their situation is in terms of being
like liquidated or
that sort of thing they they could have
a margin call
on that
separate
i think it was i think about 200 million
dollars worth of bitcoin in a separate
entity that has some
uh covenants around it they could get
margin called on that but they're also
in the position to contribute more
bitcoin from their balance sheet into
that entity
to shore up the collateral requirements
for that and so it's it's not a
liquidation or like a
you know
death knell margin call type of
situation like people were talking about
um
you know so i would say that and then
i would also just say though that like
crypto has a tendency to um
like it has fat tails from like a
statistical probability perspective and
crypto just has this tendency to
do things
that you thought were incredibly
unlikely or
virtually impossible and to have those
types of events
come to fruition
at a higher likelihood than you would
assume and that's what i mean by like
fat tails relative to like a normal
distribution type of deal
and
so you saw you know i would never say
never um
with something like that but i think
it's a very low probability i would also
think that if sailor
ever got into some kind of
uh
tough position
where
i don't even know what that would look
like
uh
you know where he contributed bitcoin
from the balance sheet into this
covenant restricted
uh
you know side vehicle that he has
he borrowed uh
like that whole situation
there's just a tremendous amount of like
uh extremely well capitalized bitcoin
bulls that like in the same way that
you know el salvador's bitcoin bonds
before you know before we had stress in
the in the bond market and they put the
the volcano bonds on hold like that
though those those el salvador bitcoin
bonds were like over subscribed and my
guess was they are over subscribed at
least in part by people that are just
very bullish bitcoin and see the
developments happening in el salvador as
being good for bitcoin broadly and
willing to support that i would guess he
would have the same type of support
available to sailor if he were to get in
into a tight spot like that so yeah i
think that's actually a really
interesting way to look at it as to uh
there's just certain things that happen
in the market uh regardless of the
economic uh kind of underwriting of it
uh there's people who say this is good
for bitcoin and therefore uh i will
participate whether it's bonds et cetera
and then if you actually can overlay uh
it is a good economic decision based on
their underwriting then there's just
even more folks who are willing to uh to
kind of step in so that makes sense
another group or a person that seems to
be in a similar but different situation
is the luna foundation and uh this idea
of trying to peg uh ust to uh to one
dollar um how do you think about the
similarities or the differences with
sailor but also kind of the potential
risks uh or things that you're looking
at uh for market and the price of
bitcoin as uh as that kind of unfolds in
that situation
i i think they are
somewhat comparable
and i would broadly ascribe more risk to
the luna situation
than i would to
sailor situation
i mean where you're you're dealing with
a you know sort of algorithmic
algorithmically controlled
but also backed stable coin
it's pretty incomparable
relative to any other
stable coin that's been in existence in
crypto there is risk present there
um
but i still think it's like you know
relatively small
um and they just had an announcement
that came out overnight about some
stability mechanisms that they're
putting in place
there are
several
stunningly well capitalized entities
that are in support of uh this luna
situation
that are the types of entities
that uh
have uh
a very outsized influence on
just what the crypto market is gonna do
broadly
like it's like you put jump and 3ac into
a room and you go how you know
this room controls how much of what
happens in crypto broadly and it's like
it's like a real a real amount of what
happens in crypto is a function of like
what jump and 3ac decide is going to
happen
and and you know these guys look like
they're in in you know a position to be
very supportive of this thing
but it is like i said a newfangled
you know type of deal and so there's
there's risk present i would say a
higher degree of risk um
present in the sailor situation but it's
not my base case that you're going to
see some some kind of blow up there yeah
i tend to think that that's probably a
very fair analysis of like there is more
risk because of the peg etc unlikely
that there is some massive uh blow up
but i think your point about
why there's a lack of blow up uh is
mispriced by people in the market right
seeing a job seeing a 3ac uh and some of
it may just be like folks in the bitcoin
community uh may not understand or
recognize uh the size the enthusiasm the
level of participation from those groups
uh in a lot of this stuff uh and then
some of it is just uh almost feels like
there's people uh in various communities
that are just cheering for destruction
of those types of things right like kind
of like i i get to say i told you so uh
which is like a very um kind of
weird exotic uh development of uh rather
than like the open-mindedness yeah i
call it i call it big short syndrome
okay explain
yeah like it's it's big short syndrome
it's like people are
begging for
these enormous blow-ups because the
people that shorted the subprime crisis
in 2008 were like heralded as such
heroes like michael bury's like a great
example of this right and uh michael
bury like hung on to this tesla short
for however long and i mean i think got
like blown out of the water on it
basically uh before it ended up working
uh which is uh there's a lot of irony to
that but um people are like always
looking to like
be the like sky is falling bare and then
like nail that trade and then they get
to like you know parade that they like
nailed some big short type of thing and
like
you know
that mentality has sent a ton of people
to the poor house over the last decade
or so or
you know looking back over
um
the history of financial markets over
over many decades uh and and uh you know
being
being overly bullish and highly levered
sends people to the poor house as well
too
um you know which i guess like what is
it like
whatever bulls and bears both get to eat
but pigs get slaughtered or something
like that so
yeah yeah and i guess part of this also
is
there's a bunch of folks who uh outside
of the bitcoin community today we saw
norell robini i guess is working on like
a tokenized dollar uh cryptocurrency uh
there's plenty of other folks who are
still skeptic bearish uh flat out maybe
even shorting the market uh but it does
feel like uh you're starting to get one
some specialization in crypto so there's
some people who are bitcoin there are
some people who are uh part of ethereum
or the smart contract platforms or nfts
etc
2016-17 maybe even in 2018 like you
could just be i'm a crypto investor and
you could pretty much touch or
understand most of the market i do think
that that bifurcation is changing a
little bit uh but with that comes this
feeling of uh like a zero-sum game where
people say like oh nfts are going to
work but x is not going to work or you
know ethereum's going to work bitcoin
won't work or vice versa et cetera like
how do you think about specialization in
the market today and then also uh is it
a positive sum game where like all of
this could work or some of it could not
work and some of it does work but like
they're not necessarily tied together as
much as they used to be
yes i mean tribalism's been around for a
long time
uh in crypto forever right um
it doesn't strike me that tribalism is
any
stronger today than it has been it's
just always been
strong
and i think that even within the
tribalism
there is a view
you know i guess like the most extreme
examples of tribalism
there isn't this view that like hey we
all we can all win here but i think once
you get outside of the like tale of like
the extreme tribalism that even bitcoin
fans and e fans and solana fans and nft
fans
the large majority of those even if they
have their favorites can still look at
the thing and go this whole pie
has a lot more room to grow
and uh
there are strong
structural inflows into this asset class
in this technology you know directional
flows to my point earlier about
uh the amount of venture capital coming
into this space
there's there's structural inflows into
crypto that um
yeah you have outflows and people are
worried about the fed in the short term
but over any kind of medium longer term
horizon that's up and to the right super
highly convicted on that and then
also like there's no other asset
there's no there's there's nothing that
derives more of its value from network
effect than crypto um it's it's an even
more pure expression of network effect
than like through value creation than
even a social media platform
and so to that end it's like if more
people are coming to crypto
um you know even if you're a bitcoin fan
and more people are coming to eath
um
or you're a solana fan and more people
are coming to like eat nfts
that broad
uh pie growing
adds to the value of the asset class as
a whole because all of it is so much
driven the value of all of it is so much
driven by by network effect and so
there's plenty of room for like
everybody to win from that type of setup
yeah i tend to agree that that is uh uh
true
one of the most popular questions i get
right now is how people can make money
in a recession as you think about asset
prices falling the fed stepping in uh
with higher and higher interest rate
increases
how do you think about positioning a
portfolio is there psychological uh
things that you look at are there
frameworks you use uh or are there
tactical things that you're employing in
terms of actually being able to make
money during a recessionary period
yeah
so i guess
recession is an economic term
i think
recession versus like
market uh
strong market like asset price decline i
think of those things as two different
things
because we could end up in a recession
in like q1 of 2023 or q2 of 2023
and
uh
like the nasdaq could be way way higher
off of its lows when that recession hits
because asset prices and economic growth
are like two separate things
and asset prices are so strongly a
function of what the fed is doing
and by the time
the fed goes on pause
or the fed slows tightening which will
absolutely rip all asset prices with
crypto leading the way
that could still be sort of like
potentially too late to cause to like
keep us from dipping into a shallow uh
inflation or a shallow recession rather
so i would i would you know kind of
delineate between
those two things
in terms of positioning you know
it just kind of depends on
what your outlook or like what your i
guess goal for
your you know everybody's in different
positions with their you know i think
there's a lot of just like kind of
everyday retail folks that that are
watching this um
you know have some cash on the sidelines
you know now is not a good time to be
using leverage at all um knife catching
is uh not a good idea for retail traders
it's like never a good idea um if you've
got cash on the sidelines when
crypto is more than 50 off of its top
starting the dollar cost average
into
uh you know buying more bitcoin buying
more east uh
historically
that has worked out incredibly well
um i think that there's no reason to
think it's not going to work really well
right now um
and
you know i think
the fundamentals of this space are
unequivocally
getting stronger
and that is not being reflected in price
action right now
but that is a temporary disconnection
as
monetary policy from central banks is in
the driver's seat
but that will pass
and it might pass sooner rather than
later um
but that will pass and fundamentals will
still will you know move back into the
driver's seat and so there's there's
nothing to be worried about from a
longer term perspective about the
viability of this asset class crypto
broadly is going to continue to eat the
world and we will get with just a small
amount of hindsight we'll look back on
this pullback like we look back on a
bunch of other pullbacks that you know
people barely remember but you just want
to make sure that you're in a position
to keep playing the game you got you got
to be in a position to be able to
continue to play the game
because the asset class broadly is going
to create trillions of dollars of value
over the course of you know this decade
and the next and probably the one after
that
that uh that makes sense to me the
number one question i'm getting from all
of the live viewers is uh they want to
hear uh your thought process behind
selling bitcoin for other assets and
some of the more tactical stuff you're
doing i don't know what you're allowed
to say and not say from like a
regulatory standpoint uh but anything
that you can provide uh in terms of uh
some insight there i think people are
super excited to hear from you
yeah so i think the one thing i'll say
is so i went on um
uh we actually talked about you pop i
went on yano's podcast like two weeks
ago the empire podcast and we were
talking about all the way back in
september 2018 when yana was like doing
the camera and the microphone set up for
the pomp podcast back then correct uh
yeah so we reminisced on that and how
far those guys have come
uh but on on that on that podcast i
talked about
this eth merge
uh this kind of this kind of eth merge
uh catalyst
which in my view
is the
most significant most telegraphed
catalyst in the history of crypto
um
and i think if you know which is like a
pretty hyperbolic thing to say but i
think if you look back on the history of
crypto
for something to be a bigger catalyst a
more significant more telegraph catalyst
than this it would either have to be
something in bitcoin or something in eth
because it was something in any other
asset it wouldn't have by definition
wouldn't be as significant as being in
those two
and like
the havings in bitcoin
uh
are different because they're
programmatic and they're also just less
significant in my view
relative to this eth merge setup which
is
ethgoing deflationary
eth turning into a yield generating
asset and if moving to esg friendly and
i think we all know what a behemoth esg
is and it's a separate conversation
about the legitimacy of that movement
but i think we can all agree that it's a
big movement and people are focused on
on esg type of stuff and a move from
from proof of work to proof of stake is
a step
towards esg
um
and
it it and it comes at a time when
eth
there's never been more institutional
eyeballs on east there's never been a a
greater willingness and ability of
institutional capital to buy eth in size
than there is today it is not the same
as the covert crash it's not the same as
the kobe crash heath would like what did
eat it down to
on the lows
it was incredible did you get down to
200 bucks
on the cobot crash lows i don't remember
the kovid crash lows i know in the 2018
crash i think it got down 70 bucks 75
bucks covid was what
holy cow
at the absolute low east got down to 90
on the cover crash nine ninety dollars
you know the market cap was like
you know when eat was ninety dollars the
market cap was like probably
i don't know 10 billion dollars or
something crazy like that right like
incredibly low
like you can't uh uh
institutional capital could not buy eth
in the spring of 2020. it was just too
small it was too unproven it was too
volatile and
the
the um
just the
the um
the thesis was not well understood for
eth at that period of time and and all
of that has changed a lot since then uh
okay
yeah so on the lows
ethereum's market cap got down to 13
billion dollars institutional capital is
not buying a 13 billion dollar asset
they cannot it's not possible for them
uh whereas now you know ethe is a
uh
285 billion dollar asset institutional
capital can buy a 285 billion dollar
asset and so
i think all of that combines together
with a set up for
and look
there is risk that
inflation remains stubbornly high and if
we go back to that orange and black
chart that we just looked at 10 rate
hikes in 2022 if we can't get these
leading economic growth and inflation
indicators to roll over the fed i think
it's just going to have to keep
tightening
and if that ends up being the case you
don't want to be long any of this stuff
uh because the price is just going to
keep going down and you know you
increase the likelihood of like a really
nasty
outcome that forces things to go on on
pause and pushes us into a recession in
a full-blown you know nasty market crash
in all asset prices um but that's not my
base case but there there there is a
risk that inflation could remain
stubbornly high uk ukraine definitely
presents risk there uh the china
lockdowns definitely present risk there
although
the people that i talk to that
understand the chinese economy the best
there's there's not agreement on whether
or not
china lockdowns are
inflationary or deflationary for like
u.s inflation measurements there's just
not agreement on that so i think it
remains to be seen on that but there's
there's
there's risk to my view for sure but my
my base case is that inflation and
economic growth indicators are going to
roll over in the coming months and then
it sets up for the fed to
decelerate tightening
relative to expectations either at
jackson hole or at the september
mid-september fomc meeting which lines
up
uh
really well
with uh when the eth merge is going to
be put on and you put those two things
together and it has the potential for
incredibly explosive price action and
crypto broadly but eve in particular
dude
if they go on pause like plus or minus a
month of the merge
is going to teleport
it is going to teleport and i think it
looks like ethan's in heavy accumulation
mode right now
and uh
you're going to get to like the depths
of the summer when there's no eyeballs
on this market when trading volumes are
at the absolute lowest and uh
people are getting all beared up and
all the spot eat is going to be is going
to be held by people that aren't in the
mood to sell it anywhere close to the
bottom and you can just and i remind
people like on the on the jo on the late
july 2021 bottom
uh which didn't really have much of a
particular catalyst to it i mean you
could look at the b word conference with
elon and jack dorsey that did kind of
put the bottom in heath went up 120 in a
straight frickin line off of the bottom
and that was nowhere near as bullish of
a backdrop as what we potentially have
with eath merge lining up with um
the the fed decelerating tightening and
so
that's one of the most attractive setups
i've seen uh you're going to have every
traditional
uh investment fund on the planet that's
going to be trying to make up their
entire year which has been going real
shitty for almost all of them up until
this point and like
if you're trying to find the fastest
horse like the borrow paul tudor jones
moniker btc will move real well off the
bottom as well too i think heath could
just like you know
so did you basically uh in some way say
hey look
bitcoin is uh
what it's been there's market structure
etc eth for the reasons you just laid
out uh you just think has more upside to
it and so you guys basically shifted and
then did you also go look at other
assets as well or like how did you think
about outside of the uh bitcoin eth you
know kind of blue chips if you will did
you guys go take a look at like oh if
everything goes up the things that are
the smallest cap will go up more or how
would you uh i guess analyze that part
yeah yeah we don't really play that game
so to speak and i think you got to be
cautious with liquidity and
as you move outside of btc and east
very quickly that stuff when the mall
gets pulling back a lot and when you're
in a you know when traditional looks
like [ __ ] like it does right now that
stuff goes no bid
to a degree that like you know that
stuff goes down 50
and then it goes down another 50
you know and then it might go down
another 50 right and uh
so i think you got to be real careful
moving down market cap the two things
i'll say is
on that one
we've been spending a ton of time in
metaverse and and
bitcoin gaming play to earn
in-game assets we've been spending a ton
of time on that uh and are captivated by
that space it's very early um
it
the the those assets the way the in-game
economies work right now
it's like
bob you know you know i talked about
this before it's like like you say like
bitcoin's the most reflect reflexive
asset on the planet uh well like play to
earn is like definitely more reflexive
than bitcoin like it's inherent in the
nature
of uh the way those in-game economies
work that it's just very very reflexive
so to the downside
it just gets like real nasty in a hurry
um
so
that's not where
i think we're in the mood to deploy
capital in anticipation of a bottom
but then all this stuff's gonna it's all
gonna probably run harder than
everything else off the bottom as well
too
um but but you wanna you wanna see which
of these projects sort of make it out of
you know some really nasty price action
and actually can retain users and grow
users
and compel people to get back into these
in-game economies so we're paying a lot
of attention to the innovation that's
happening in metaverse and played hearn
uh
mostly from the sidelines in terms of
capital deployment but we're paying a
lot of attention to it and then i think
the other thing you would look at is
like
if if eth runs hard what happens with
the rest of the layer ones what happens
with solana luna
avalanche
cosmos dot
um
near like what happens with all of these
and i think it remains to be seen um i
think
historically
you know you could see eth run hard and
then have some kind of rotation into
other layer ones the exact timing of
that is like definitely difficult to say
trying to time that is like you know not
really a game that i would suggest most
people try and play
um but you know eats market cap is
so so like i'll give you like an example
right look so east market cap is let's
call it 300 billion right now so let's
say it doubles from here
uh
that would be like 5 000 eth a little
less and that would be like 600 billion
dollar market cap
uh and then
and then let's look at like solana for
example so
solana has a 23 billion dollar market
cap so if east doubles
to a 600 billion market cap and solana
also doubles then eth would be 600
billion
and
uh
solana would be
46 billion
market cap
but
and then like
solana relative to eth that would be
flat over that period of time right
because like they both doubled right
and i think at some point the market
looks at that relative value spread
and they go okay eat the 600 billion
dollars solano's
you know 46 billion dollars you know
whatever that's that's six seven percent
relative market cap that spreads too
wide and it should be something closer
to ten percent or fifteen percent or
twenty percent of these market cap i
think there's a potential for that type
of relative value trade to emerge and
the timing of that you know remains to
be seen and like i said that's like uh
that's a pretty tricky game to play so
yeah it um it feels like there's just so
much uh
to underwrite as you expand the kind of
investable universe uh and i think this
kind of idea of a market structure and
it brings this kind of full circle in
this conversation to like it may all be
one trait right
in terms of uh it seems like crypto uh
goes down together it goes up together
uh but you have to start to underwrite
uh risk and reward and how do you do
that is uh uh is pretty difficult
um before i let you go uh i have two
questions one uh i think that you were
in la and i think you've moved now to
texas uh
what's uh what's the geography arbitrage
or whatever that uh uh kind of thought
process there i'm sad you didn't move to
miami but i understand i think you're
from texas uh and then also uh one of
our sponsors is eight sleep what's up
what's the sleep schedule looking like
these days now that uh you're back in
texas even though the market is uh
literally as we're talking in a free
fall and uh we're just watching
everything bleed everywhere
yeah so did did move full time to austin
november last year my girlfriend and i
were doing airbnbs for a while last year
in austin
bought a house in austin here full-time
i'm from college station which is like
two hours north of here my family's
still there my mom would have killed me
if i had if i had if i had moved from
california state taxes to a zero state
tax environment and i'd gone to miami
instead of texas my mom just would have
killed me
um yeah so and austin austin's great
love austin um
enjoying my time down here enjoying
the proper suburb life like like rapidly
adapting to the proper suburb life after
spending a decade in like venice and
then manhattan and then chicago before
that
um
so enjoying my time down here and then i
haven't ate sleep uh and love it and um
pretty focused on sleep i've got this
like a garmin watch if you like know
this thing it's got a pretty pretty good
sleep tracker
on it uh i'm pretty good about getting
at least seven to seven and a half hours
a night
um
i
need to move my bedtime
up a little earlier i'm doing about 12
30 to 8 30 right now i need to get that
to like 11 to 7 because there's um some
of the like circadian rhythm type of
stuff like i should be but i don't know
i've always been a little bit more of uh
of a night owl but um
yeah
i'm super focused on sleep and and i
think uh
when i skip it i feel it immediately and
um
you know i'm 37 years old i'm not
getting any younger so you you look 22
and uh you're already tracking
everything that's
[Laughter]
uh as long as you're tracking everything
right like i think that part of it is uh
once you know what works for you like
every everybody's different but once you
know what works for you like to your
point if you stray from what works you
feel it like once you get into it right
and i'm the same way it's like if i uh
you know i need eight hours right so if
i don't get eight hours i'm like dude
you just know like i'm a little bit more
irritable i'm a little bit sluggish like
all these things and so it's just like a
daily reminder like hey get your ass to
sleep stop you know wasting time all the
stuff so makes sense where can we send
people to find you on the internet uh if
people are not already following you
yeah uh twitter's great travis
underscore cling on twitter
uh we write this monthly update letter
so if you go to ikigai dot fund
is the fund uh website and then if you
click on content
uh it kicks you over to a different
website which we just had to do for
regulatory reasons but we have this
content depot
called kana and katana which is the the
pin and the sword in japanese and that's
got all the pass
market monthly update letters
uh you can sign up for future ones there
and it also has this like little tab
there where you can see just the every
month the bulleted
monthly highlights from all the past
monthly updates it's like a it's
probably the best
thing to show like
crypto skeptics to give them a sense of
like how much has happened in this space
over the last like two years or whatever
when you look at when you look at it all
in one place
uh we've covered a stunning amount of
ground since the first time you and i
got on a podcast in september 2018 i
mean it's like
i mean even since we did the coveted one
in may of 2020 dude we've covered a lot
of ground and the the
all this fed tightening stuff all this
stuff is a hiccup dude it's like all uh
this is this this too shall pass
and the outlook for this space broadly
has never been brighter so everybody
should be excited yeah i tend to think
that is a great way to uh
to view the market
bleeding would stop that'd be nice but
uh other than that my friend i uh i
appreciate you coming on i think people
really enjoyed this uh and uh we'll
definitely have to do again in the
future so thanks so much
always a pleasure man all right talk
soon